[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález esta ha sido
una semana de muchos movimientos en
torno a la atención en ucrania en este
programa hemos analizado cada semana los
hechos y los avances relacionados con
este tema primero a lo largo de esta
semana pues se mantiene ese frenesí
diplomático las visitas a moscú esta vez
por parte de olaf scholz el canciller
alemán también varios representantes del
gobierno italiano han estado en
conversaciones con sus contrapartes
tanto en moscú como en kiev en días
pasados eeuu alertó sobre un ataque
inminente de rusia sobre ucrania cosa
que no ha sucedido hasta el momento por
el contrario el kremlin anunció el
retiro de un número significativo de
tropas que a los ojos de la casa blanca
no ha sido considerado como algo
significativo veamos
en un aparente alivio de tensiones rusia
anunció que algunas de sus tropas
empezaron a dejar la frontera con
ucrania tras terminar ejercicios
militares que aseguró son de rutina
moscú tiene cerca de 130 mil soldados en
la zona no dejo claro cuántas de ellas
seguirían ucrania dijo que no creerá en
el retiro hasta que lo compruebe por sí
misma posición que comparte con el
presidente de eeuu de bailén hasta ahora
no hemos verificado que las tropas rusas
estén regresando a sus bases hemos sido
transparentes con el pueblo
estadounidense y con el mundo acerca del
plan de rusia y la seriedad de esta
situación para que cualquiera pueda ver
por su cuenta qué es lo que está pasando
william por su parte el presidente ruso
vladimir putin aseguró que no quiere una
guerra pero contrastó con su postura
clara ante un posible ingreso de ucrania
a la otan hemos oído que ucrania no está
preparada para entrar en la otan hoy
conocemos esa tesis pero luego dicen que
ucrania no será aceptada mañana entonces
será aceptada cuando esté preparada
puede que entonces sea demasiado tarde
para nosotros por eso queremos resolver
esta cuestión ahora mismo
las relaciones económicas entre alemania
y rusia han sido claves para la aparente
desescalada de tensiones pero reino
unido- aseguró que hasta que no haya una
salida a gran escala de las tropas rusas
no lo tomará como un verdadero gesto y
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen pidió reforzar las
medidas coordinadas para castigar a
rusia si viola la soberanía
a pesar de esto para la otan y para la
casa blanca en washington este
movimiento de tropa solamente ha sido
eso un movimiento una reubicación de
algunas tropas que estaban desplegadas
en la península de crimea las partes han
indicado que las discrepancias sólo
podrán solucionarse por medio del
diálogo y la diplomacia pero la gran
pregunta es qué tanto puede resistir el
canal diplomático antes de dar inicio a
una confrontación cómo se está viviendo
en el terreno allí en la región del
donbass en la ciudad de hardcore tumbas
lugansk mariupol el este tire y afloje
que hay entre rusia y ucrania la otan
eeuu y por supuesto la unión europea que
opinan los residentes muchos de ellos
separatistas o ciudadanos simplemente
del común que quedaron en medio de estas
confrontaciones que desde ya el 2014 se
ha cobrado la vida de cerca de 14.000
personas en los combates que han tenido
lugar allí en el este de ucrania pues
para analizar esta actualización en
torno a lo que está sucediendo en el
este de ucrania en la región del donbass
saludamos en kiev la capital ucraniana a
alexander slip él es analista político
del instituto ucraniano para las
relaciones internacionales en la ciudad
de varsovia en polonia está pablo
gonzález periodista él es politólogo
también recientemente estuvo en el este
de ucrania cubriendo allí de primera
mano lo que está sucediendo en esta
región y también con nosotros está desde
moscú la capital de rusia xavier colás
periodista corresponsal de france 24
quien también recientemente estuvo en el
este de ucrania ustedes lo vieron
reportando desde la ciudad de hardcore
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24 guión bajo s arroba santi logo
que es mi cuenta personal les recuerdo
la etiqueta numeral el debate efe 24
dejen todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas y comenzaba yo el programa
hablando de este tire y afloje entre
ucrania o rusia y occidente y veíamos
muchos movimientos diplomáticos en lo
que llevamos de la semana quiero
comenzar entonces con alexander en la
ciudad de kiev sobre sus impresiones de
lo que han sido las visitas del
canciller alemana también italia
tratando de aportar algo para desescalar
esta atención con rusia que se comenta
allí en ucrania en torno a estas visitas
que han comprometido tanto a moscú como
kiev
gracias por esa cuestión aquí y sentimos
que ahora puede estar apoyando nosotros
por parte del diploma ser pero no de
verdad no veo ninguna presión sobre
presión diplomática músculo que siempre
hablan muy tranquilamente sobre esa cosa
los eeuu están más listos a
presionar a analizar esa cosa como una
amenaza muy grave europa está tratando
como si es posible
acordarse con con putin y col con el
gobierno ruso pero todas las partes
diplomáticos deben entender el objetivo
primario de rusia es cambiar la
estructura de seguridad europea y
cuestionar el estado original pues aquí
no gran es si estamos
[Música]
es muy bueno que grupo nos apoye pero
deben hacerlo más con más
presión y del otro lado de la frontera
en moscú en rusia que impresiones hay de
estas visitas que ha habido en los
últimos días allí en moscú también en
quien ya lo mencionaba yo xavier con las
nuestro corresponsal que se comenta allí
en el kremlin
todos los mensajes que han ido
recibiendo
gente de la selección de que con esta
crisis rusia sobre todo estaba
interesada en sentar especialmente a
eeuu no tanto hablan europea porque ha
hecho lo posible por ningunear la
presentar eeuu en la mesa de negociación
y ver qué es lo que podía conseguir de
la otra parte después de años de
desencuentro en cuanto a todos los
mensajes alarmistas que hemos escuchado
durante estos días especialmente de eeuu
pero también de la otan y de la unión
europea hablando de un inminente ataque
ruso han sido recibidos con bastante
sarcasmo por parte del kremlin del
gobierno ruso creo que era ayer cuando
putin un poco poco después de levantarse
por la mañana preguntó a sus
colaboradores que se podían decir a qué
hora era esa invasión rusa que estaba
viendo en los medios occidentales y hoy
mismo la cancillería rusa ministerio de
asuntos exteriores
se dirigía a también a los medios
fundamentalmente los británicos y los
norteamericanos pidiéndoles que
informasen de cuando iba a ser esa
ataque ruso porque dicen en el
ministerio de exteriores
en planificar las vacaciones
si incluso varios medios internacionales
se han reportado haciendo críticas
precisamente a eeuu por haber afirmado
que había una invasión ya inminente al
este de ucrania algo que no ha sucedido
hacemos la aclaración
pero lo que sí es cierto es que eso
escaló un poco más la atención entre las
partes pero hasta ahora no se ha llevado
a cabo voy a entonces ahora a ver la
cara de la moneda desde el lado europeo
con pablo en la ciudad de varsovia en
polonia en un país que está con una
frontera de más de 500 kilómetros con
ucrania un país que ha estado siguiendo
el minuto minuto lo que sucede allí
también ha habido llegada de muchos
ucranianos que ante la atención presente
pues han decidido marcharse y abandonar
ucrania que dicen allí en europa que
dicen allí en polonia país que se ha
comenzado a preparar para un posible
éxodo masivo de ucranianos y también
llegada de extranjeros de otras
nacionalidades que están en ucrania
polonia realmente es uno de los países
que más más poblar que nunca llena tiro
desde 2014
se calcula que pueden estar cercanos al
millón de menos ya y sí que es verdad
que no ha habido tantos programas a
nivel digamos
gubernamental pero sí a nivel municipal
se ha preparado muchísimas plazas para
eso para esos posibles refugiados
en caso de guerra por lo demás polonia
buenos ha tomado esto contra el pecado
precaución y preocupación pero también
con cierta calma bueno porque polonia se
siente un país de la otan sabe que el
paraguas de la otan la protege entonces
es un poco diferente no como como se
puede lo pueden percibir los ucranianos
no que no tienen este paraguas además a
polonia han llegado soldados
norteamericanos o más
polonia y ya tienen desplegadas muchas
tropas cerca de 20.000 efectivos en la
frontera oriental con bielorrusia no que
sea digamos la frontera problemática no
desde esa de ese estado un que es la
unión de rusia bielorrusia y entonces
bueno
calma pero una calma prensa por supuesto
voy a antes de comenzar a hacer un poco
el análisis político quiero preguntarle
a pablo ya xavier que estuvieron
recientemente allí en terreno en la
región del donbass comienzo
preguntándole a xavier en moscú cómo es
el día a día yen del este de ucrania
cómo es esa tensión que hay con los
residentes con los
separatistas las tropas las supuestas
tropas rusas que están del otro lado de
la frontera como es el día a día allí de
acuerdo a lo que usted pudo ver
pues con bastantes problemas como más
pesimismo del que nosotros somos
conscientes desde nuestras respectivas
capitales pero con menos ahora mismo del
que hemos visto estos días en los medios
de comunicación allí en las ciudades en
las que yo estado cerca del frente una
vez que poca gente pensaba que rusia
fuese avanzar mañana esta semana o este
mes y en cambio tampoco creían que todas
esas conversaciones telefónicas o en
torno a una mesa más grande o más
pequeña entre los políticos vayan a
servir para solucionar un problema que
les afecta diariamente
de una manera muy cotidiana para empezar
muchas personas tienen a sus familiares
al otro lado del frente yo estuve en la
parte ucraniana y me encontré pues con
un hombre que llevaba sin ver a su
hermano ocho años porque está en donges
y el nivel jarkko o por ejemplo señoras
mayores en el vino galés que está a unos
dos kilómetros y pico del frente pro
ruso que llevan pues varios años
aisladas de sus familiares la guerra ha
trastocado la vida cotidiana es mucho
más difícil sobre todo para la gente que
no tiene un coche pues moverse al
hospital acudir las revisiones también
hay un incremento de precios diario
aunque esto está ligado en buena medida
a la situación de ucrania y lo que
decían muchos para terminar de alguna
manera de dibujar
ese cuando lo que hay ahí es que se han
acostumbrado ya a la guerra no tienen no
tienen miedo de más guerra pero tienen
pocas esperanzas de que a corto plazo se
pueda salir de esa situación de bloqueo
de tierra de nadie especie de maldición
que les ha caído encima y pablo sus
impresiones en qué parte del este de
ucrania estuvo usted y cuéntenos de sus
impresiones de lo que vivió allí sé que
tuvo algunos encuentros no muy amistosos
con las autoridades pero tengo la duda
si fue con autoridades ucranianas o si
fue con un grupo de los artistas
no sólo de nuestra parte general me han
gustado la línea de frente con los
gritos de seguridad ucraniano porque
bueno están nerviosos y entonces ha
habido pues andan mandan más nerviosos
de la cuenta con algunos periodistas
nuevas acreditaciones etc bueno yo he
estado en la ciudad de dedecker de libro
que está a 200 kilómetros y después en
el donbass pues en áfrica que está bueno
que es prácticamente línea de frente el
después de algunas ciudades más como
secreto nets y realmente pues coincido
con contra el yerno no la gente es
altamente pesimista no espera una guerra
y es que también tenemos que dar cuenta
que llevan ya prácticamente siete años y
medio viviendo en una zona de conflicto
entonces para ellos no es acostumbrarse
a ellas días ya viven esto no como me
comentaba una persona él se dio cuenta
que ya no le molestan para nada los
tiros de ametralladora la artillería
etcétera puede hacer su vida normal
tranquilamente en su casa aunque oiga a
lo lejos disparos no lo cual es una
situación totalmente anómala pero que
ahí se ha vuelto cotidiana y después
pues bueno lo decía muchísima gente
joven se va solo quedan la gente más
mayor la gente más vulnerable la gente
que no tiene a donde irse así por
ejemplo me encontré con una chica en
nadia que estaba paseando con con su
hijo y ella es de toda la vida de ahí
del donbass pero con un hijo ya habla en
polaco porque ellos viven en polonia y
vive y vienen cada seis meses hasta el
donbass a visitar a su madre que bueno
que no por vender por edad y por salud
pues no se puede ir de ahí entonces ese
es el día a día realmente el donbass una
situación bastante triste no mala
economía más de acción de seguridad y
vida rotas no creo que ha dicho xavier
con muchísima gente que tiene sus
familiares separados no de polaridad de
frente
retomar la comunicación con alexander en
la ciudad de kiev para preguntarle si
hay una especie de causa común entre los
ucranianos a raíz de estas amenazas que
han empezado a tener desde hace ya
varios años por parte de rusia si esto
ha logrado definir esa identidad
ucraniana porque la identidad entre
rusia y ucrania tiene unas líneas muy
difusas por ese pasado histórico que
tienen los dos país a lo largo de los
siglos los ucranianos este tipo de
conflictos les ha permitido
consagrar su identidad unirse como
nación y hacer una causa común para
enfrentar esta amenaza externa como lo
vio usted si muchas gracias de verdad
una cuestión muy buena porque
no no puedo decirlo pero es una ventaja
de ese conflicto que por finalmente
después de el caribe de la unión
soviética nuestra sociedad está unida
desde este al oeste
contra una amenaza
pues si la sociedad aquí está está lista
para resistir eso y esto es cierto
porque cada de fines de semana la gente
civil como yo estaba visitando los
entrenamientos militares para saber cómo
va a saber cómo manejar las armas como a
las fusiles para aprender la táctica
básica y eso es la realidad en que vive
la capital de khyber en el siglo 21 es
un poco raro a escuchar por parte de los
europeos pero si vivimos como si esto es
cierto que
finalmente la gente que tuve dudas y
vive ahí en tumba tus dudas
sobre la nasa rusa finalmente ellos
entienden que si nuestros socios están
situados en el occidente y rusia no va a
ayudar y proveernos nuestro desarrollo
si lo que no puede entender es que
ucrania la apuesta por integrarse más a
europa y dejar un poco de lado su
integración que tuvo a lo largo de los
años y en los siglos con rusia y tiene
un futuro
mucho más claro tal vez en europa
alexander como en la convivencia en esa
región del donbass porque étnicamente
todos son eslavos son pueblos eslavos
pero lingüísticamente son diferentes y
tienen muchas costumbres en común pero
también algunas costumbres distintas a
lo largo de los años la convivencia era
completamente pacífica entre ucranianos
y rusos y dependiendo de el idioma que
hablaran pero como se fue deteriorando
esto que fue lo que detonó este
sentimiento separatista este sentimiento
de unirse a rusia alejarse de ucrania
apostar por volverse regiones
rusoparlante 100% y dejar de lado el
idioma ucraniano para decir vamos sobre
el separatismo en términos de
politología separatismo debe a tiene sus
causas aquí el separatismo tiene causas
para que sea que la idioma cultura no es
una causa para separarse si a la minoría
rusa en crimea y en donde basta pero
sobrevivimos con ellos perfectamente
durante todos esos años por ejemplo yo
hablo ucraniano hablo ruso habló que ya
no como como es mi lengua materna
pero está bien sea la gente a bauzà en
en ucrania pues ese conflicto fue
provocado por la propaganda rusa en el
2014 y
eso hay que entender solamente muy
importante que los separatistas las
repúblicas como independientes no pueden
existir sin la espalda si tiene el apoyo
militar y económico de luz pues ese
separatismo no tiene
raíces naturales como tiene por ejemplo
el separatismo
y otras ciudades de países donde hay el
separatismo nacional el seco el
separatismo en ucrania es apoyado por
moscú es un separatismo artificial
javier un separatismo artificial
propaganda rusa esa es una perspectiva
que podemos ver una de las opiniones que
puede tomarse desde el lado ucraniano
pero desde el lado ruso también vemos un
discurso muy fuerte por parte del
presidente putin hablando de constantes
hechos de discriminación precisamente a
la población rusoparlante allí en el
donbass e incluso lo ha calificado como
genocidio y este es uno de sus
argumentos aparte de lo de la otan
también para estar haciendo presencia
allí financiando estos grupos
separatistas y haciendo presencia a
través de por ejemplo otorgando
pasaportes rusos a los ciudadanos que
tanto creen los rusos en este discurso
del presidente putin y que tanto esto es
un discurso de guerra y algo de verdad
la realidad de lo que se vive allí de
acuerdo a lo que usted vio en el donbass
vladimir putin se ha preocupado
muchísimo por el idioma las tradiciones
y el folclore
del este de ucrania cada vez que ha
necesitado o ha querido ha barajado
intervenir en el país es una zona de
ucrania que atraviesa muchos problemas
desde hace muchos años que ha estado
bajo distintas leyes lingüísticas y sólo
ha sido cuando ucrania ha amagado con
acercarse a la unión europea y tal vez
en el futuro a la otan cuando de repente
en moscú les empezó a importar muchísimo
toda esa gente que trabaja en la zona o
que trabajaba en la zona de lumbar o en
las minas de donde stc donde tienen
multitud de problemas y de la
discriminación lo que pueda sufrir
respecto al ruso es sólo uno de ellos yo
creo que hay una distancia sideral entre
la existencia de un genocidio en ucrania
y la realidad aunque sí que es cierto
que
hay una política lingüística
bastante radical por parte del gobierno
ucraniano actualmente y que está
poniendo en aprietos a algunos creadores
y también bueno una cierta incomodidad a
gente que quiere hablar el ruso que en
definitiva es uno de los idiomas
de ucrania junto con el ucraniano creo
que no hay nada nada nada malo en ello
es una lengua propia del país como
también lo es en el ucraniano yo creo
que las divisiones que
existen ahora mismo lucraría son
fundamentalmente políticas ningún caso
étnicas ni religiosas es decir hay gente
que en un determinado momento y estoy
hablando sobre todo el año 2014 se
sintió muy decepcionada y desencantada
con el gobierno de que tampoco es que
antes fuesen muy próximos pero digamos
que el cambio a la caída del régimen de
yanukóvich pues extranjerizó a algunas
personas
decidieron algunos movieron su mirada
hacia hacia rusia hacia moscú inspirados
un poco por lo que había pasado por con
esa anexión express que había llevado a
cabo rusia en línea se trata de un
problema fundamentalmente político que
se ha enquistado pero que en buena
medida ha sido magnificado no sólo desde
rusia sino también desde desde otros
desde otros ámbitos y además que una
realidad similar se ve en otras
exrepúblicas soviéticas en moldavia se
habla ruso pero también se habla hemos
dado que es una variante del rumano en
casa que está en el idioma oficiales
kazajo y también en el ruso son
situaciones similares paso a preguntarle
a paulo que está en varsovia en la
capital de polonia sobre los movimientos
que pueda dar la unión europea hemos
visto muchos esfuerzos diplomáticos
a lo largo de los últimos días pero tal
parece que la respuesta de moscú hacia
la unión europea parece restarle
importancia al grupo europeo al bloque
europeo si se compara con la respuesta
que le está dando a eeuu como que es un
actor que trata de minimizar qué
impresión tiene usted al respecto
bueno más que más que
una respuesta a la unión europea una
europea no existe existe una respuesta a
ciertos jugadores de la europea que son
básicamente francia alemania y en menor
medida pues pueden ser italia o incluso
españa en algún momento no existe
moscú es una es una política que llevan
desde hace tiempo practicando no la de
ignorar la unión europea la de no
tratarla de igual a igual e intentar
llegar a acuerdos puntuales con los
países digamos que importan dentro desde
la propia unión pero dentro de la buscó
práctica está esta política de intentar
de subir no intentar buscar grietas en
la unión europea también es cierto que
la propia unión europea no tiene una
postura común no no es lo mismo por la
misma una misma apuesta la que puedan
tener por los países bálticos que ha
puesto lo que pueda tener alemania qué
bueno que está más interesado digamos en
el gas y el comercio o la postura que
pueda tener incluso portugal españa
aunque son países bastante más alejados
y para los cuales no es una cuestión de
seguridad entonces nos y sabe que a día
de hoy los que importan nunca ya nos
tiramos marcan las tendencias de la
política ucraniana son los eeuu y lo
hace saber en cierta manera también para
tratar de
de restarle importancia a los países
europeos no como lo dijo putin después
de la reunión con macro o no qué bueno
que tampoco podría ir a un acuerdo
porque no es él quien decide entonces es
una política que se le da bien a moscú
pero que la propia unión europea por
desgracia pues tampoco puede de momento
cambiar esta tendencia e intentar ser un
cuadro comunión europea sigue siendo
jugadores alemania francia o algunos
países separados pero no la unión
entonces yo creo que no podemos hablar
de una de una respuesta de moscú a la
unión porque básicamente no no la toca
como tal buscó incluso las cartas que
hizo o no las propias esas propuestas
que el editor le solicitó a la estados
unidos ya la otan no la vio europea
paso a preguntarle a oleksandr en la
ciudad de kiev es sobre ese escenario
que hay sobre la mesa que posiblemente
podamos ver algún tipo de movimiento en
torno a esa decisión del presidente ruso
que recibió un aval del parlamento de la
duma para que reconozca a las repúblicas
de donges y lugansk como independientes
son repúblicas autoproclamadas desde el
2014 esto es un guión similar a lo que
tal vez a lo que vimos en con crimea y a
lo que vimos con afasia 27 osetia del
sur con algunos matices en georgia qué
posición hay en kiev es sobre este tema
qué movimientos puede tener kiev si esto
llega a materializarse
por primero en que es tan seguro que es
eso es un chantaje y tensión prisión
otra vez porque esos territorios son
territorios de ucrania y si se les
reconoce como independientes eso va a
destruir otra vez nuestra soberanía
territorial pues
incluso están
100% contra esa decisión y lo van a
utilizar
por primero por segundo
existe un protocolo de minsk y en
protocolo de minsk está escrito
ucrania debe negociar más es esa cosa de
bombas debe ser negociada entre ucrania
y la hora seguía y rusia también pues el
intendente independencia de estas
repúblicas
destruye ese diálogo pacífico y otra vez
la causa de esto desde esa es esta
situación agresiva está excelente porque
está provocada por moscú pues aquí
estamos cierto que se por mí por mi
opinión rusia no lo va a hacer no lo va
a reconocer pues porque esto va a
destruir su propia posición diplomática
es súper bien sobre ese conflicto sí y
cuál es la perspectiva en moscú xavier
es sobre esta posición está posible por
el posible reconocimiento de estas
repúblicas pues un as bajo la manga que
tiene putin qué tan viable puede ser
como que es dos cosas la verdad es que
el propio desde el propio kremlin han
aclarado que en efecto esta decisión si
tomar esta decisión de reconocer la
independencia de estas autoproclamadas
repúblicas dinamitarían los acuerdos
debéis que no está conforme a los
acuerdos de minsk y ahora mismo lo que
está intentando el camino es lo que dice
es forzar a kiev a que cumpla los
acuerdos de minsk así que de momento
putin no va a tomar esa esa baza de
reconocer esas repúblicas pero hay que
tener en cuenta que el parlamento ruso
no es el parlamento ucraniano lo que
quiero no es el parlamento italiano
tampoco lo que quiero decir es que si el
grupo parlamentario de los comunistas y
no hablemos ya del grupo parlamentario
ruso vida que es el partido
gubernamental se han llevado a cabo esta
proposición en el parlamento día siendo
aprobada desde luego no se trata de una
casualidad que ha sorprendido a brasil
leyendo los periódicos por la mañana da
la sensación de que de alguna manera es
una baja que sí tiene algunas que se
quieren guardar la banda y que en la
manga y que tal vez podrían usar el
futuro
me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero cerrar
hablando precisamente de ese acuerdo de
minsk que tan vigente están los acuerdos
lo pactado en ese documento todas las
partes involucradas culpan y señalan a
otro de los partícipes o participantes
en este acuerdo de no cumplirlo
violar algunos de los puntos comienzo la
ronda entonces con pablo desde su
perspectiva que tan vigente está este
acuerdo que tan necesario pueda ser
refrendarlo o llegar a una nueva mesa de
negociación y generar un nuevo pacto un
nuevo acuerdo entre las partes
pues seguramente sería fundamental puede
intentar llegar a un nuevo acuerdo
porque los acuerdos de vince que están
vigentes pero no no son viables porque
simplemente no puede cumplirlo porque es
un son los acuerdos que no le favorecen
para nada no sería si los cumple en el
mejor de los casos tendría un caballo de
troya dentro de ese territorio en forma
de esas repúblicas que pondrían un veto
continuo en cualquier aspiración
euroatlántica para o para ucrania
entonces desde dos casos podría
significarle al gobierno de haití a otro
otra revolución
etcétera etcétera muchísimos problemas
internos entonces todo se está
aumentando personas a bolivia para que
los cumpla pero es descargar es claro ya
desde hace años que quien no puede
cumplir los entonces sentarse a
renegociar qué es lo que tampoco quiere
nadie que no se quiere o sería
fundamental aquí hace falta una una
voluntad de encontrar un diálogo que por
ahora creo que ninguna de las partes
realmente le está demostrando
alexander en la ciudad de kiev
precisamente a ucrania no puede cumplir
estos este pacto alcanzado en el acuerdo
de minsk que tan difícil
cumplir las cosas que fueron pactadas
allí vale ucrania ucrania dice que
seguridad primero política segunda lo
que yo hablo sobre la seguridad es que
los militantes deben ser desarmados y
las
las armas deben ser retiradas vale
adónde regueras a rusia a su país de
origen es lo primero que se debe hacer
quien no cumple pues sólo después es
posible a celebrar las elecciones
democráticas como lines inc como lo
entendemos en el palais globalmente pero
rusia dice lo distinto y por primero hay
que celebrar las elecciones cuando las
tropas se están situando en tumbas y la
frontera con cruces no está controlado
por el gobierno creen y sólo después
ucrania puede controlar a esas esos
territorios pues eso nos hace aceptable
para qué y por
esto que no puede cumplir esas es ese
acuerdo claro y la perspectiva de moscos
abierto
rusia insistió muchísimo en esos
nuestros acuerdos que se consiguieron
precisamente porque el gobierno
ucraniano el escrito que no estaba
acorralado perdiendo posiciones en aquel
difícil arranque de 2015 y por eso fue
precisamente por lo que rusia empujó con
sus tropas y por eso fue por lo que se
firmaron los acuerdos en unas
condiciones movimientos favorables para
quien yo creo que es cierto con sido
bastante con pablo sí desde una especie
de estado de negación creo que no nos
damos cuenta de que es muy poca gente
quiere que esos acuerdos de paz se
cumplan unos acuerdos de paz que hay que
decir que sí que ha servido para algo
por lo que porque por lo menos no hay
una fase aguda de la guerra siguen
muriendo personas en ese en ese
conflicto pero no se trata de una guerra
abierta de cara al futuro probablemente
había que renegociar algo distinto y en
ese sentido probablemente moscú piensa
que el tiempo juega en su contra porque
rusia de perdón ucrania es cada día un
país mejor armado y un poco más sólido
desde luego más de lo que a
no renuncia a la idea de recuperar a sus
territorio de alguna manera y sobre todo
no se resigna a cumplir esos acuerdos
que parece que fueron firmados por una
ucrania distinta a la que existe hoy tal
vez en esa gente esta denuncia de que el
tiempo corre en su contra están algunas
de las tensiones que hemos visto estos
días pues estaremos atentos a los hechos
que vayan ocurriendo en ucrania en esta
escalada de tensión que ya lo decíamos
involucra a rusia a ucrania la unión
europea ya estados unidos que ha
mantenido en vilo a la comunidad
internacional a mis tres invitados en
moscú en kiev y en varsovia les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
haber hecho este análisis habernos
aclarado cómo está la situación allí en
el terreno y la perspectiva ucraniana
que ha sido casi un lujo para medio
latinoamericano o medio con difusión en
américa latina' a tener a alguien que
hable en primera persona de política
ucraniana les agradezco ustedes también
por la sintonía y pueden seguir con la
programación de france 24 y por supuesto
dejando todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con nosotros
[Música]